hello welcome to this video on building
a node.js
application using sql server end-to-end
in this tutorial you'll learn the basics
of creating a node.js application with
sql server
by creating a simple calendar app to
give you an idea what you'll be creating
your application will be a simple event
calendar that uses vue.js
and material css on the front end
secured with a login
to allow new users to register for their
own account
and the front end will communicate with
your secure api
to create and delete events i'm excited
to step you through this project so
let's get started
before we get started on the code
we need to make sure that you've got a
couple of things that are required to
complete this tutorial first is
you need to have node.js installed and
you can check that in a couple of ways
one is to
open up a command prompt or terminal
depending on what operating system
you're using and type in the command
node v this should print out to the
console
the version of node that you have if you
get an error message or if the version
of node
that you have installed is below maybe
version 10
then you're going to want to install an
updated version
you can do that by going to nodejs.org
and clicking on the big green download
button
if your own uh mac or linux or if you're
using
the unix or linux
subsystem for windows i highly recommend
that you install nvm and that is the
node version manager
and this gives you a command lined
option and it makes it so much easier to
work with
upgrading node and being able to install
multiple versions of node like on my
system
if i do nvm ls i see that i've got
version 12 and version 13 installed and
i can switch
easily from one to the other and
i can also do upgrades
the other thing that you need to have
installed or
access to is sql server
and if you have access to a development
instance of sql server that's great if
you need a local instance
then there's a couple of ways you can do
that one is if you're on windows and
you're comfortable with
installing something like sql server um
you can go
download the
sql server developer edition
i used to use this a lot when i was
developing
uh net applications on windows
and it works fine it's got all the all
the features that you can
possibly need with sql server but if
you're on mac
or linux or if you don't want to
um mess with installing a
a complicated server application like
sql server then
you can use docker if you don't already
have docker installed you can go to
docker.com and and go through
the options to find docker
to download there's a free community
edition
that it works fine and that's what we'll
be using in this tutorial
and um
so i'm going to step you through uh how
to
install docker or how to install sql
server
using docker so the first step
is to make sure that docker is running
so if you got docker
you should have some uh commands
that you can use
and it appears that i do not have docker
running i've recently
upgraded my my system
and so docker is uh needs to be
installed
all right so i've got to install it too
looky here
let me uh let me install this real quick
and then i'll get back into the video
all right so now i've got docker
installed and i'm ready to
uh continue so the first thing you need
to do is pull down
the latest docker image for sql server
and you
do that by using the docker pull command
and the full command is docker pull
microsoft slash
ms sql dash server dash linux colon
2017-latest
and when you run this the first time it
should take
a few minutes depending on your
bandwidth
how much what your download speed is
it'll download the image
and you can run this again anytime and
if there's an
update to the image it will download the
latest version
once you have the image downloaded then
you need to create
an instance of that image as a container
and use the the docker run command for
that
the docker run command in this case is
going to be
dash d to create a background
damon um so that the server runs in the
background all the time
without having to have docker running or
without having to
have this running in the terminal uh
we're
specifying the name of sql server so
that
you can easily start and stop by using
the name sql server
and then there's some environment
variables that we have to pass
one is the to accept the eula
and the other is to set the password for
the system admin account
and you can change that to whatever it
is that you you
want to change that to uh we're setting
the
the sql uh product identifier to the
developer
edition of sql server
and then we're mapping some ports so by
default sql server runs on port 1433
and so we're mapping our local 1433 to
the containers 1433
and then finally we're specifying to use
the image
microsoft sql server linux 2017
latest as the image to
create this from i already have
a container named sql server
so it's giving me an error i could back
up here
and and give this another name and
create a second instance sql server but
i'm
i'm not going to do that all right so
but i do need to start it when you
run or do docker run it's going to
uh start that server automatically after
it creates it
i need to actually call docker start
sql server and now my sql server
instance is running as well now
um next thing we need to do is to create
our sql server database
and uh and this you know create uh some
a table
and seed some data into it um to do that
i'm going to use a tool called azure
data studio
you can do actually do this from inside
visual
studio code if you're using that as your
editor
there's a plugin for it i'm going to
show you real quick how
where to go look for that so if you
search for
azure data studio you should land on
this page and you can
find instructions on on an installer for
your operating system if it's a zip file
or an installer for windows
so download this application
if you don't already have it and install
it and
then we'll get started on the next
step
all right so if you install azure data
studio and launch it
you should see a a window that looks
similar to this we're going to create
a new connection to our sql server
database
so the server will be local host we're
going to use sql login authentication
username we can use the system admin and
then the password
that was passed to the
docker command when we initialized our
container
and we can check the box to remember the
password
and there are some other options but
we're just going to go ahead and connect
with this
all right now we're connected to the
database and we need to
create a database
for our application
you can use command n or control n to
create a new uh query window
and in here we're going to issue some
some commands
so we're on the master database right
now we can say create database
i'm going to call it cal
actually i've already got a database
name calendar
so i'm going to drop that
and f5 don't do this in production right
this is we're able to do this because
we're in development so now i'm gonna
this is the uh this is the command i
want you to run
create database calendar
and go press f5
that's executed the query and now
you can change your uh current database
to calendar so now inside
you know make sure that you are in the
calendar database you wanna
double check say use calendar
and and press f5 and that will switch
your current
connection over to the calendar database
you don't want to do this on the master
database so now we need to create a
table
for our calendar events
and we're going to have an identity
column
that just automatically increments
and we're also going to specify this is
the primary
key for the
table and this value cannot be null
we're gonna add a user id
in barca 2050
and it cannot be known
a title
not known a description
a description is a keyword so
for sql server we're going to wrap that
in brackets so that sql server knows
that we're
using this as a identifier for our table
uh label uh column instead of
using a keyword let's make this
invar car a thousand
it can be null
we need a start date
of type date that is not null
now um and then a start time i'm
splitting these out
separately just so that
it makes it
a little bit easier to deal with the
data that's stored so that we don't have
to
extract parts out of the date the time
part
we're just going to have these things be
separate in the database
that way you could have a date like an
all day event
kind of thing as a start date without a
time associated with it
and uh not have to you know
have a flag for that or have the time
be specified as you know 12 a.m and
assume that
means it's a date or a an
all-day thing and then we're going to
have an end date
that is a type date that is normal
nullable
and then an end time
we're also going to want to go ahead and
add an index
for this table i mean it's overkill for
a tutorial but i want you to know that
you can specify indexes at when you
create a
new table um using it
you know you can name it whatever you
want to but i always like to have a
convention of idx for index
the name of the table and the name of
the columns that are included in that
index
i just know ahead of time that we're
going to do some queries based on
the user id and sql server
likes to have some hints or likes to
have indexes
for performance for performance
that'll make this much better down the
road all right
we've got our our full create table
command here
and press f5 or you can go up here and
press the run
and now the table is created if i try to
create the table again
it tells me that there's already an
object named events in the database
if you want you can specify
uh like if you have some uh some
ddl um type statements like if you have
a
script file that you may want to put in
production
like uh or a migration file you can do
things like
drop table if exists
events and run that i mean
um just know that if you
have that in there then it's going to
it's going to drop that table so that if
there's any data
in that table it's gone
and this is good or useful in
development when you want to just start
over clean
with a fresh copy of your database
with with all the tables that you might
create
all right we're through setting up a
sql server one more step
i want to go ahead and add a couple of
rows in here
that we're going to want
some data to play with later on
in when we're setting up the application
insert into events
user id title
description start date
start time
those are all our columns
and then our values
we'll say user1234
this is a appointment
description stuff
and our start time is going to be
um our start date will be march 31st
and time will be 2 30 p.m
and the end will be i'm going to say no
no for the end date and time
let's go ahead and add a second row
same user1234
we'll say it's an online conference
no description
this will be on we'll start
on april the 1st there's no start time
and we'll end on april
the 2nd no in time
so now if i run all of this it will
recreate
the the table for me and also um
insert two rows into this database
now we've got the database set up and
ready to go let's dive into some node.js
code
all right switch back over to your
terminal or command line
and we're gonna set up a
directory for our project um
change to whatever directory that your
you
store your your projects in uh for this
demo i'm gonna
create something in my project demos
folder
so make their
node call it whatever you like
and then change to that directory
and the first thing you need to do when
you're setting up a node.js project is
you need to
initialize uh that
folder use the command npm init
dash y if you want to accept the
defaults if you don't specify
dash y then node will prompt you to
answer
several questions about the name of the
project and
your contact information and the license
and so forth
all these things um can be you can set
these defaults using the mpm command
so if you go search for npm init
defaults you should be able to find
um how to set the defaults for things
like the
the version and
the author and the type of license you
want to
have for every project going forward all
right
so now basically what npm init does is
it creates this package.json file
for us gives us a starting point for
adding
the dependencies that we need for the
project
when you use node.js there are lots of
great frameworks that you can choose
from to
build web applications
express is one of uh is probably
the most well known and popular
in this tutorial i'm going to use happy
it's my personal favorite it was
originally created by
walmart engineers uh suitable for
building apis and services
and complete web applications so in this
prompt
we're going to run npm install
happy happy
now it's going to download some
dependencies and and get that
that first happy instant setup
you may want to specify just to make
sure that
if you're watching this video and maybe
it's sometime in the future
just for compatibility you may want to
specify uh add it on to the end
at 19 just just
to lock down a particular version of
happy
in case there's a breaking change in a
later update that doesn't
work with this uh the code in this video
so happy happy app 19.
the other thing that i like to do when
i'm setting up a new node.js
applications
is to use eslint eslint is going to
alert me to common mistakes
javascript issues errors uh
things that could cause me pain
if i don't like
initialize my variables or or something
like that so eslint is a
is a great way to do that and um so
also use npm install but this is a
developer dependency this is not
something we would put into production
so
you want to use the save dev flag
and um i'm going to use eslint
and eslint config reverent geek
these this is my own
you don't have to use this but this is
my own
like collection of eslint rules
that i like to have uh that helps me to
format the code
consistently and and some other things
so
we'll wait for this to install
eslint uh needs to know what kind of
rules
to use so i'm gonna create a
file called eslint rc dot js
and i'm going to put into this code file
the the set of rules that i want to
eslint to to use when i'm
linting my code um
i've got my own config for that and i
can never remember
uh what the uh how to what the settings
are
so here's a a tip you can type npm
docs in any
package and it will automatically open
up
the the readme for that package
so i can uh
know that hey i need to create a config
file
and put uh these these this rule set
in here so this is the one that i want
it's for node.js
and now i can switch over to
uh visual studio code
i'm going to be using and inside this
eslint rc
js i'm going to add my
module exports that tells eslint
what to do all right if you um
were curious about what i what i did to
launch
uh digital studio code there you can
also add this
code as a command line parameter if you
press
command shift p that brings up the
the palette and if you type in the word
install
you'll see that one of the options is
the shell command to install code
in your path so if you're working from
the command line you can type
code anywhere and it's going to launch
that current folder
in your visual studio code editor really
handy
all right so now we've got that um
we want to create our first
node.js web server with happy
let's create um i like to organize my
code
everything in for my servers under a
source folder
so we're going to create a new folder
called source
and in here i'm going to create a new
file
named index.js
now you may be wondering why i'm using
ustrict at the top
and because you may
know already that in the browser
if you're using any modern javascript uh
if you're using
like the imports exports uh the module
type settings that
you don't have to use use strict if
you're using modules
in on the front end but for node.js
modules in the in that sense of using
like the import exports
uh syntax for for things
um that's not a yet a default
and if you don't specify you strict
then you're uh
you're not running in strict mode
whereas in the browser strict mode is
is pretty much guaranteed to to be
uh run all the time if you're using
uh modules if you're using a transpiler
like
uh it's going to add you strict to the
top of all your files
automatically but node this is something
that we need to do
today so
we're going to require in our server
module
which we'll create in just a moment
and we need a start
server function
wrap this around to try catch
we're gonna create a config object
specify our host is localhost
and port is 8080.
create an app we're going to wait on
our server
passing in our config
and we're going to await
server.start
server running at
and now we just need to set our catch
statement
and finally
we'll call start server
so our asynchronous function that
creates
um oh
this should be app.start not
server.start you saw
you may have seen um see this is where
es lent
uh helps me to keep making stupid
mistakes so
um the squiggly underline under app
indicates that app is declared but its
value has never never been used
like oh well i put in the wrong thing it
should be app.start
and so now everything goes back to not
being
read again all right so we've got our
index
now we need to create our server module
again starting with u-strict
and we're going to require in
our happy module
i'm going to specify requiring in
a routes module which we'll we'll create
in just a moment
again um if you're creating a hello
world
application you could put everything
into one index.js file
and and make it work but that's not
going to serve you
really well going forward so i like to
organize my code
in even in the beginning into things
like
separate server.js which will make
server.js
easy to test later separating it
separating out things like my routes
plugins
which are the equivalent of
middleware that you may have used
middleware for express if you've ever
played with express
plugins is what happy uses and
you know just different sections of code
into their separate files because i know
over time as the project grows i'm going
to want those
uh kinds of disciplines in the project
and there's there's unfortunately not a
whole lot of guidance
out there on how to set up
projects and it's all a preference thing
you know there's no one
set way of of
defining what node.js projects are
supposed to look like
that's one of the beauties of of node in
javascript you can
do things the way that you want the way
you like them
all right so now we've got our routes
module imported we're going to create
our app that takes
is a synchronous function it takes in a
config
we're going to destructure the host and
the port off of
the config object and create an
instance of our happy server
using the host and port
next uh we're gonna
store the config
on the uh server.app instance and this
will come in handy
later on in the project i i know ahead
of time
that we're going to want to find some
things like
the sql server connection information
we're going to
put that all on the config object later
on
and then from anywhere inside the
application at any time we can
use server.app to get to those
configuration
values which is really handy
and then finally we'll
use our register our routes
passing in the server and then finally
return
server
and last but not least we need to set
our module.export this is the magic
that uh for of common js
that allows us to uh um
expose to the outside world
to anything that consumes this module
that's what helps us to expose
uh what objects or functions or
classes if you want to use classes
are available when you import that
module
all right now
we're still missing one thing and that's
our routes
so i'm going to create in my
source folder a new folder called routes
because i know i'm going to be adding
multiple routes
or collections of routes at some point
and
in the routes folder create an index.js
again use strict
and we're just going to module.exports
we can just say
we need just one function called
register
that takes in a server
and uses server to register
a route
a method is get
path is the root so we're setting up
what this is doing is setting up a route
that's listening for
like the default document so the uh
when you go to localhost 8080 without
specifying a route name
or anything this is what's going to
serve that up
and then we need to define a handler
which is a
an asynchronous function
happy passes in a request object
and this request toolkit
for whatever reason it just call it h
i guess it's short for happy uh but it's
the
request toolkit that has lots of things
that that are like utility functions and
all kinds of cool stuff but we're not
going to use either one of those in this
hello world type
first instance so we're just going to
return
the text my first happy
server
and we're done
now one thing before we run this is we
want to go into package.json
and change the main to
uh to look for source slash index.js
this is so if you run
node at the command line it's going to
know where to find the uh the entry
point
for the application so now you can start
the application
we'll do that by going to the command
line and typing in node
and a period and
oh i must have messed up something with
the the output
uh let's switch over real quick
i forgot my dollar sign you probably
saw me do that all right
those are template strings a template
uh tempered little temp template
literals
in javascript so
let's press i'll do control c to stop it
and run it again now i got the
the text that i expected and you can
you know copy and paste this into your
browser whatever
the the terminal settings that i have i
can use command
click on a url which is really handy
and when you browse to
the url you should see the text my first
happy server
sweet success
your first node.js happy server
all right go back and
stop that server you can press ctrl c
now before we get into writing code to
interact with sql server
we need a good way to manage our
applications configuration
such as the the sql server configuration
or sql server connection information
node.js applications
typically use environment variables for
configuration
however managing actual environment
variables can be
quite a pain especially if you're on a
on windows
so there is a module that we can use
uh in node.js called dot end
that exposes a an env configuration file
to node as if they were actual
environment variables
so for us to get started on this we need
to
install uh emv as a dependency
and here i'm specifying version 8
because that's the
the version that the latest version is
going to work
with this particular project
and now we need to create a dot env file
you could
create this in visual studio code i like
using the touch command on
on mac it's just convenience
so now we have a an end file
that's empty and we need to put some
configuration information in here
so i like to specify
the it's a common thing to have
a node environment um variable
and you definitely want to set node env
equal to
production when you deploy
an application to production that's
going to give you
a lot better performance
now we need to specify our happy server
config
report equals 8080
host equals local host
i'm going to go ahead and specify a host
url
just as a shortcut i know i'll need this
later
and then also later on in the
application
this tutorial we're going to add
security some authentication to our app
and we're going to use cookie sessions
cookie based sessions
to uh to manage that security so i need
to specify
if i can type a server a cookie encrypt
password and this can be this can be
whatever you want you can be just a
big long string of gibberish you want
something that's
that's secure uh it does need to be
at least 32 characters long so
i'm just going to call it my super
awesome
password stream
that is at least 32
characters long
change it to whatever you you want and
now we need some sql
uh server config
we need to specify our sql user is in
production
you're definitely going to have
different credentials set up
for uh your application so you you do
not
ever use the system admin account
in production but for development um
we can we can get away with it um
if you're real pecu or
if you're using a a database
server that's hosted somewhere else like
if you're using a development instance
of sql server
in your organization for for example you
you probably don't have the sa password
account anyway so
you're going to use whatever developer
account that you have
so specify that
i need to specify the sql database
this calendar
i need to specify the sql server name
in our in this case i'm using localhost
but this will be whatever
if you're using a development server
that's
hosted somewhere else you can put that
in there
and then something that you'll need if
if ever you want to
deploy this application to azure you
need to set
sql encrypt equal to true
for azure if you're for local
development you're going to
set this to false and then finally
i'm going to go ahead and add some octa
config in here because later on
uh in the application um we're going to
add
authentication to the app so that people
can
log in and enter dates for their own
thing and we're going to need
at some point an octa-org url
and an octa
client id
we'll change these later
and off the client secret
another thing to point out is that um
if you're using a source control system
like git
you do not add this dot env file to your
source control
you need to ignore set it to ignore this
file
because each require each environment
requires a custom env
like different sql server connection
information different
port or host information and you don't
want to expose any of these
secrets in your github repository so
that other people
could find them especially if you're
creating an open source
project right you don't want to
accidentally
check in a file that includes hey here's
my sql
database in connection information or my
uh client secret
for authentication typically what
open source projects will do is create a
a separate env sample file that includes
placeholders and then in the readme
we'll say you need to you may you need
to make a copy of this file rename it to
env and change all the
values to be for your environment
all right so we're going to to use
this configuration information we're
going to create a new file under source
called config.js
and we're going to pull in our
env
module
and there's one thing uh you have to
run the the config function
on emd and this is going to read in that
env file and then add
all the environment all those values
that are in there
to the node.js process
so that it looks like to node uh
that these are environment variables
that are set
in the in the environment
let's pull off because environment
variables are always
uppercase we're going to pull off
all these values and return something
that's a little
more palatable for
node.js or javascript so instead of
dealing with uh all these uppercase
values
so we're going to pull off port host
host url the cookie
encrypt password
sql server
sql database
sql user
we're going to pull those off of the
process.env
which is node.js's built-in
environment that's how it exposes
environment variables
inside the any node.js application
we're going to
check our sql encrypt value if i can
spell
and now we'll um export
all this configuration
mapping all these values to
things that make more sense
like sql we'll create that as a separate
like an object
within the object
this will make it easier like down the
road
also going to specify um
the uh the version of sql server client
that we're going to use for
node.js
it's currently requiring
uh to set and enable
a with a board either true or false
otherwise you get a a warning message if
you don't specify
what uh arithmort it should be true
one other thing i want to pat uh pass on
is a
good tip a lot of times
when you're deploying an application or
changing environments or something like
that
uh it's really easy to miss adding
a environment variable that's required
uh that your application expects and if
if the environment variable is not
specified
then um you know it could cause issues
in your application some unexpected
behavior and you're thinking
you know might take a while to track
down so
one pro tip i would say
is uh assert that all the values are at
least present
in uh your configuration so
one way you could do that is to use the
built built-in assertion library that
comes in
in node
and then after you you pull in all this
information
just use assertions
assert that assert
port
and just duplicate this for every
um every required
environment variable in the case of this
application
every environment variable is required
for this application to work
like it's intended so
just as a an exercise if you want to add
all those assertions into your own
application
this could save you some headache down
the road
now we need to update the uh
our main index
to change where we hard coded our
configuration here
to use our new config module
so up here we'll say const config equals
required
config
delete this
and now we can just pass the config into
the server now we can get to the fun
part
in this step you're going to add a route
to happy
to query the database for a list of
events
and return them as json you're going to
create a
sql server client plugin for happy and
organize
your data access layer in a way that
will make it easy
to add new apis uh in the future
so first we need to install some
dependencies
the most important being the ms sql
package
so back to the command line we're going
to say npm install
ms sql version six and
uh also in this step we're gonna install
fs
extra version nine fs extra is
or fs is the built-in node.js library
for file system
like for reading and writing files
i personally like the fs
extra library that takes that extends
the built-in
file system and gives
get some nice utilities around
reading and writing json files
now back to the project we're going to
add our
ax data access layers under source let's
create a new folder
named data and under data
create a new file for index.js
creating seek connections to sql server
is a relatively expensive operation
there's a practical limit to the number
of connections that you can establish
and by default uh the ms sql packages
connect function
creates and returns a pool of objects
a connection pool increases the
performance and scalability
of an application so in the life cycle
of
a node.js application or an applica or
any
type of application that that connects
to a
a database like sql server
you're going to want to create that
connection one time
for the lifetime of the application and
use that that same connection objects
over and over again
so in uh what we're going to do
is set up a client that we can use
from anywhere in our application to
make those those queries and then the
client itself is going to handle
you know creating an instance of a
connection and keeping that connection
alive
for the lifetime of the application in
this index.js file
we're going to require in
an events module that we'll create in
just a moment
whoops
and we'll require in
the ms sql module
and we're going to create our client
function which is
an asynchronous function that takes in
the happy server
and our happy config
and we're gonna initialize a
pool object
this is how we're gonna keep that
connection pool around
we'll create a couple of internal
functions on
this client one is close
pool
so the application is shutting down or
for whatever reason needs to close the
connection pool it can do so
and then we'll create a function called
get connection
check if pool already exists
then return it
but if um this is the first time
uh this connection uh has ever been
created
then we'll um create a new connection
pool set pool equal to
await sql.connect
passing in our our config
and then we'll we'll check if on error
if there's an extra an error or anything
we'll just
force a closed pool
and finally return
our connection pool
and if there's a an air
error of any type that's unhandled
we'll also go on so we'll log this to
the console
and set the tool equal to null just to
be safe
finally our function that we're we're
defining here
the client function we want to return
something and that's going that
something is going to be
an events object
where the events are going to
expose functions for
doing queries or operations on the
events table
the calendar table
we're going to pass in our sql client
and our git connection because those are
two things that
every
data access layer group
of queries and and commands are going to
need
the sql object and the get connection
function
and then finally we need to
export
a client
so just to reiterate when using sql
server with node.js
one of the most critical things to get
right
is handling connection errors when they
occur and internally this uh sql data
module has two
important functions that we've we've
talked about get connection and close
pool the get connection
returns the active connection pool or
creates one if necessary
and when any connection errors occur the
closed pool makes sure that the
previously
active connection pool is disposed
to prevent the module from from trying
to
uh to continue to reuse it
all right so under the source data
folder
let's create a new file called utils
and in here i want to
add some code that's going to
help us to read in a bunch of
query files we can define
sql files as external
dot sql files and read those in when the
application loads
we're using our the fs extra module
that we pulled in and we're also going
to uh
use the uh join function
that's part of the built-in path library
for node and the path library
or module deals with
folder file paths
we're going to create one function
called load sql
queries
that you'll pass in a folder name
use the process current working
directory
and we'll say in the source folder
under data look for this
folder name by convention
and then get a list of all the files
that are in this folder
and then filter that list of files
to be only
files that end with
the dot sql
extension
and then let's initialize a queries
object
and then we'll loop over
for const
before of is is a really handy
uh newer convention
for looping over arrays and objects and
so forth
we're gonna create a query
by reading in
that those that file join with our
file path the name of the file
and we're going to specify encoding
is utf-8
remove the the sql extension
from the file name
and so we're
we're creating a property on this
queries object
that's set that specifies
for instance maybe we have a
query file named getevent and so
queries.getevent without the sql
connection
is going to be equal to the contents of
that getevent.sql file
and finally return queries
and now we're ready finished with that
so let me back up and
explain again it is possible to embed
sql queries as strings in your
javascript code
but i believe it's a better practice
to keep your queries in separate
sql files and load them at startup
using a utility like this this
utility module loads up those all the
sql files in a given folder
and returns them as a single object
so next we'll create a new folder under
source data
called events let's create
a new file index.js
and let's go ahead and create a new file
called get events dot sql
in the index file
let's read in
the the require the utils module
and let's create a register function
that's going to initialize all this
we're expecting a sql connection
a sql object and a get connection
function
passed in
first we want to read in all those sql
files
so let's say sql queries
equals await utils
dot load sql queries
and passing in the folder name of events
and let's create a
a get events function
types in a single user id
we're going to create a get a connection
from our
get connection function
that was passed in we're gonna
create a new request
in the request we're going to define
our our query parameters and
the query that we're going to use so
in this request we'll say request dot
input
the user id it's a
50 type and we're going to use
the user id that was passed in as the
value
and then we're going to return
request.query
using sqlqueries.getevents
again by convention when this
reads in all the
query files it's going to expose a get
events because this sql file is named
get events
and finally our register function
needs to return a uh that we're
exposing get events
again yes lent to the rescue i forgot my
equals
and now in this get events sql file
let's add the query
for getting a list of events so we'll
say select
these are all our our columns now it's
it's not necessary to
wrap all your column names in brackets
but it's it's a good discipline it's a
good practice to get
in uh in the habit of
because we know that description is a
key word and we definitely need to wrap
that in brackets
so i'll select those things from
the events table
where user id
is equal to whatever value we pass in
as the user id parameter and then
order these events
by start date
and start time
so you you're going to notice that we're
in the in this sql file and the sql
files that we
create later on in the tutorial that
we're using a parameterized
query and that's to guard against
sql injection attacks you never want to
see
in any code whether it's nodejs or java
or net or any language building
someone building a query string using
um by concatenating strings and values
together always use parameterized
queries
next we need to create a database client
plugin
uh to make it easy to run those these
sql queries
from other parts of our application so
from our routes we want to be able to
initial our get our sql client and
run a query to return from a particular
api
endpoint and
other as i mentioned before in other
frameworks like express
uh this concept is usually referred to
as middleware
but unhappy uh uses the term
plugin so under source let's create a
new
folder called plugins
and in plugins let's create a
file named index.js lots of index.js
files
one of the reasons why index.js is used
so much
is that commonjs
recognizes index.js as like the default
file
in a folder so it's a it's a shortcut um
it you could name it anything that you
wanted to but when you require in
a module that's in a folder you would
have to specify
require plugins slash
whatever that file name is whereas if
you have an index.js file
this you can use the shortcut require
slash plugins
and it's going to automatically look for
a file name index.js and read that in
so it's just a convenience thing
so in this plugins
index we're going to create
um our
module we're going to
um we're also going to create a
a sql plugin so we're going to require
in
this sql module
now you've seen me use this pattern
quite a lot
this uh creating a register function
and expose exporting a register function
on all these top
level folders like the routes and the
data plugins
again this is just a this is just a
convention that i like to use it's
um with specifically with happy
uh because happy also
has a
registered mechanism um so i'm just kind
of
repeating that pattern uh in my own code
as a convention there's lots of ways
uh you can alternative ways to to
register
plugins and routes and so forth that
wouldn't require
this but this is something i've i've
come up with is
that as a project grows
there's you'll always know that there's
one place
to go in any of these folders like the
data folder the plugins folder the
routes folder
you want to go straight to that index.js
and
see where things are are being
registered
when the application is initialized
so that's our main index let's create a
new file
called sql.js
we're going to require in our our entire
data folder
it's going to initialize all all the
read in the sql files and do all that
kind of stuff
and then
to be a plugin in the happy ecosystem
you have to export a very specific
looking
object this object needs to have a name
property
we'll call it sql it needs to have a
version property
and we'll just set this to 1.0
and it needs to have a register function
that takes
takes in a server
uh when happy registers plugins it's
going to pass
the server instance to every plugin
so that you can do cool things with the
server
um we're going to grab the config
remember we we stashed the config
for the entire application onto
server.app
well now we can say
server.app.config.sql we're just going
to grab
the sql object off of that config
and we're going to create our client
passing in server and the config
object which is just the sql connection
information
and then last we need to expose
the client to the rest of the
application this is a mechanism that
happy has
the server.expose function
you can specify client or specify the
name of the property that you want to
expose
and then the object or function that you
want to expose
what this does is when uh happy
is initializing and it's registering all
the plugins
that you've defined it's going to
create a uh
a an instance or or provide a way
for you to access those plugins from
anywhere else in the application so
in this case we're going to expose
the database client where we can get to
it
easily from any of the routes anytime we
need to
and finally we need to update our server
to register those plugins
so we're going to add
plugins requiring our
plugins folder which is going to read
the
the index.js file that's in the plugins
folder
and then after we create our instance of
the happy server
after the config
then we need to await
our plugins dot register
so now our plugins will be properly
registered
well our next step is to add an api
route
that execute the get events query and
return
results as json you could add this route
to the existing
source routes index however as
an application grows it's be better to
separate
routes into modules that contain related
resources
so we're going to create a new folder
under source routes
and close some windows
uh
create a new folder named api
and here create a new file
of course index.js
and this will be like
an index.js that you know as we add more
routes to
the api we could just bundle those all
into
this this index.js so we're going to
require in
our events api
module that we'll build in just a second
and then we'll export
a register function
that takes in the server
and runs await
events.register
so let's also add an events
dot js file and in here
let's export
a register function
that takes
a server argument
and uses that server to register
a route this time the myth this
the method for this is also get the path
will be api
events and then we're going to set a
config
for this um this route
um actually
let's just let's just say handler
we don't need a config yet so we'll say
our handler
is an async method
that takes in a request
and now we can let's wrap all this in a
try
statement go ahead and finish the try
another tip while i'm here is that
you don't have to use the console to log
errors
like in production you probably want
an error logging mechanism it's out of
the scope of this tutorial but
you may want to look at something like
happy pinot
and there's lots of other loggers out
there too
winston
i can't think of any others off the top
of my head
but those would be better ways of of
logging
errors instead of just logging them to
the console
unless in production you have some way
mechanism of
capturing those console log errors and
and
capturing those in a way that you can
get to them later
but for now the console log will work
just fine
so in our our try statement we can now
get our
database plugin right off of the request
so the request includes
a server and we know off of server
we can access plugins using the plugins
property
and our plugin is registered under the
name
sql because that was the name of the
plugin and then we
exposed uh the client
from that plugin when we registered it
so um request.server
and then from server you can get to
plugins sql
and the client object
so now we have our database object and
for now we're just going to hard code in
our user id
which is that user1234 that's what we
inserted into the database
and now we can say
let's get a weight db dot events
because that's the the data access layer
as we were building that
we created an events object
and we have that one function on the
events
object get events and we'll pass in our
user id
and then finally we'll return response
dot record set now when you bring back
a
a database response
or uh when the response from the from
sql server comes back
it's got um maybe some i don't remember
what all properties it has
uh off of that response but it could
include things like
the number of records and you know just
metadata about the
um about the response and
you know a sql server response can also
include
multiple record sets uh could have
multiple queries
from like a stored procedure um
so the sql client
ms sql module that we're using
supports all those different scenarios
in this case we just want the record set
property off of the response and return
that and this
is automatically uh returns it as json
which is why we when we created the
table in the first place we
used the
no i can't remember if camel case or
pascal case whichever the case
which whatever the appropriate name is
uh
you know we start with the lowercase
letter and have
uppercases in the middle that's
that's the convention that you'd
typically see with json data that's why
we named
those uh column names that way so that
we didn't have to do any mapping
when we to make it look more like
javascript our json so
that's all there is to it for the uh the
routes api
and we need to update our routes
main index to register
this new api so in routes
slash index will uh
require in our
our api folder which will automatically
load that index.js
and then in our regis
register function will await
api.register
passing in the server
and i think we're ready to test this
let's go to
our command prompt
and type in node space
our server is running we'll go to the
the server here we still got our first
happy server but if we go to the route
slash api events
boom there's our json data the two
rows that we added to our sql database
early on in the tutorial so we have a a
title of one or an id of one title of
appointment
description is description stuff and so
forth
so that uh that gives us what we expect
well now that we got this working let's
get some real
users in our application so manually
building
authentication and user profile
management for any application is
is no trivial task and getting it wrong
can have disastrous results you don't
want to be
rolling this stuff on your own it'd be
better to
have a security expert at your side
and that's what octa does to so to
complete this step you're going to need
a free octa developer account
and to do that you're going to go to the
the octa portal
developer.octa.com and you can click the
sign up button here at the top or the
create free account
uh this account is always free it's good
for up to a thousand
active users per month um
really has uh everything that you could
you could need for building
uh applications and adding
authentication
login password resets all all that kind
of stuff
so sign up for an account
and then after you sign up
then you'll be uh at
the octa
dashboard
and from here you want to click on
applications
click on add application
we're gonna be we're building a web
application
so click on web and then click next
and now you can name your application
let's call this
uh node sql app
the base uris and all these things are
already set up as we need them
uh i purposely choose chose to use port
8080 because i knew
that you know we that's kind of the
default
for an application that we're building
or adding in octa
so all these you can leave as defaults
click done
and now um on this page
under the general settings down at the
bottom there is a section
labeled client credentials these are the
two values that we need
to put into our environment file
so click the little copy to clipboard
icon and switch over to
our application and go to the env file
and we'll paste in the client id
copy the client secret and paste that
in
and then last you need your org url
and to get that click on the dashboard
to go back to the dashboard and you see
right here
in the uh the top right
your org url so copy
um this url whatever that is
it'll be different from from mine
of course and paste that in
in your config
one last thing you may want to do is to
enable
self service registration so that
is what gives
your customers the ability to uh
when they go to use your application if
they don't already have a login there's
a
there'll be a link that says if you
don't already have an account you can
click here to sign
up so it's it's basically adding a sign
up link
to the login form and to do that
you're going to go to the users menu go
to
registration and on this page
there's a look for this self-service
registration if it's
enabled great if it's not click edit
change this to enabled and
save it there's also other things on
this form like if you want to add
additional profile data
to your login and registrations
all right that's done so now
we need to build our ui in these next
steps
um we're going to add a front end to our
node.js application
using embedded javascript templates or
ejs
and vue.js
first we need to install some
dependencies to support
our authentication rendering those
templates
and serving up static files
so let's go to the command line we can
stop our server now
we're going to npm install um
happy bell which is an oauth
authentication library
for happy happy boom
which is a error handling uh response
library happy
cookie which is a cookie
session authentication session
management system for um for happy
we're going to install happy
inert which is
used for serving static files uh the
cookie
we need to install version 11 and boom
is going to be version 9.
let's see what else inert
we need happy vision which is
the template engine
allows us to bring in different whatever
kind of template engine that we want for
server side rendering
and then we need ejs
the embedded javascript templates and
that is at version
three so let's install these
and now let's go back to the application
and we need to add
a an authentication
plugin for our application
whoops i went too far
so under our plugins folder let's create
a new file
named off.js
we're going to require in
our bell module
man i can't type
and we need our cookie module
and let's check if we're running
in secure uh a secure environment
a meaning like ssl tls
um and we'll just assume
that's based on our node enviro
node environment environment variable so
if it's
if we're running in production then
we're going to
assume that
we're also running under using ssl
certificates
uh otherwise in development
we're just using plain http
so module.exports
we're exporting a a a javascript object
which is our our plugin definition so
just like our sql plugin we have a name
property we're going to call this off
version default to 1.0
and we need a register function that
takes in
a server the happy server
and we're going to await
server.register those
plugins that we need the bell and the
and the cookie
plug in and
now we need to grab our configuration
off of the server
server.app.config
and we need to define a couple of uh
what happy calls
strategies authentication strategies
so the first authentication strategy is
for our
our cookie sessions
so it's a session we're using
the cookie uh plugin
and then the configuration for our
cookie plugin
is uh then the name we're gonna name it
octa oauth
we need a path
we need to set a password which is going
to be our
our cookie uh password that's defined
in the environment file
and then whether or not this is secure
and we need to set our redirect
if if someone's not logged in we need to
redirect them to
a new route
of authorization code slash
callback
that's one strategy we need to add
another strategy
for our oauth octa-based
login so everything else in the
application is going to be using session
cookies the session cookie is not there
it's going to redirect to
to the octa authentication strategy
which will trigger a an octa login
so in here we're going to call this
strategy octa which uses the bell
plug-in
and the configuration for this plug-in
the provider is
octa
config is uh we need to specify the url
uri for um
where to go uh when the person
needs to log in and that is specified
using our octa url
in our config
we need a
um to set the
i'm using the same cookie password
which i just realized did not spell that
correctly up here
also specifies whether it's secure
the location is our config.url which is
in our environment variable set to
localhost
colon 8080
and we need our client id
which comes from our
environment variables under config.octa
client id and the client
secret
i think that's all and we're going to
set
the default
strategy for our website
to session so all routes that are
configured to use
authentication will default to session
and
if the person using the website is not
logged in as a session
and that route requires authentication
then they'll be redirected to the uh
the octa strategy which will log them in
uh set them on the flow of logging into
octa
or registering with octa if they don't
already have an account
last thing we want to do is this is just
a a really nice
um
this is it's kind of like a bonus tip of
using happy
what we're going to do is create a an
extension
on on happy that is
like hooking into a a request life cycle
event so
on pre-response like this means
uh in on every request that's made to
the happy server before the response is
sent
back uh or or processed
uh by the uh by the route
we want to intercept that and get and
add some
some of our own information to that
response
so this also takes in a request
and the the happy tool kit
and we're going to check is the request
response a
a view so we're
we're filtering out like calls of the
api we only want
uh this to be triggered
when um when a
view is being rendered and sent to the
client
so if it's a view then we're going to
say
um let's check
to see
if the
person requesting this is authenticated
if they are then we're going to
set some some values is authenticated
is true is anonymous
is false
the email address of the of the current
person is
can be found under request dot off dot
artifacts profile
email first name is also available
that's first name
and then last name
and if they're not authenticated then we
want to
say is authenticated is false
is anonymous
it's true email it's an empty string
first name an empty string
last name is an empty string
so there's our auth object and we want
to decorate
the response
the context with this
auth object and we'll be able to use
this context
within our views our view templates
to check is the is the current person
uh authenticated or not and if they are
we can
quickly be able to access their email
and first name and last name if we want
to
uh put that in the
response and then finally
after all this we want to return h dot
continue
so this is part of the the life cycle
of a response
now we need to update our plugins
uh index.js to register our off
plugin as well as the other plugins that
we've recently brought in like the like
the ejs
templates so in here
we're going to require in ejs
inert for static files
vision
for our template engine support
and then bring in our our own
auth plugin
and now let's update our register
function to
not just register one
um well
let's see instead of just registering
the sql function
we'll register an array of objects
which will be our off the inert
vision and sql
and then we need to configure our server
view engine
so we'll use we'll do that by saying
server.views
in our configuration the uh
engines we're using we're only using one
ejs
which is relative to
this is the path to where to find
these templates and um
we're gonna use the built-in under
underscore underscore der
name uh which is just a built-in
node.js shortcut for getting the the
current
directory of the the application
and then the path
to our templates is going to be
uh in the templates folder
sorry the der name is actually pointing
to
like the current plugins folder that
that
this module is running in
and we're going to specify that layout
is true so we're going to have a
a layout template and the
engine will look for a file
specifically named layout.ejs
to be like the wrapper template
that goes around every page
all right
so let's add our our server templates
under the source folder create a new
folder
named templates
and we'll create that layout file
layout.ejs
and i'm going to just copy in some code
here
and walk you through what this looks
like some so html code
um we got a doctype html a head
um that includes
uh a title so this title is using
uh some ejs syntax to
when when it renders on the server it's
going to look for some data that's
passed to this view
that includes uh a title
value and it's going to inject that into
the title tag
setting or we're referencing a uh
material icons font from
google and we're specifying that we're
uh using an index.css file
which we'll add in in a moment we're
including
a navigation partial so this is a way of
injecting
yet another template into the current
template
and then our our content so
all the other templates that are using
this layout this is where
this content will go and then we've got
a script tag here at the bottom
that includes an index.js which we'll
also add in them in a little while
so we need a next add a new template
for our home page index.ejs
and again i'm just going to copy in
a whole bunch of
code to save some time
and in this container
we're using container class so we're
going to be using
material
css as like a css framework
so our classes container if
um the current user is authenticated
then show them
uh render this app div if they're not
authenticated then
render a header with a a message and a
login button
so depending on the logged in or not
it's going to change the way that
the page is rendered
and i jumped ahead i copied in too much
stuff
way too much stuff whoops
so that's all we need for the index.ejs
the next is um we need to edit
a a template for
our partials so
under the templates
we need our navigation partial so create
a file
named our folder name partials
and in parcels create a file name
navigation
ej and here
we're going to create a nav
a nav tag and um
again we're using the is authenticated
to conditionally show
a login or logout button and this is
where
the in both of these cases of the of the
home page and this navigation file
we're looking is is the current person
authenticated
and the way we're able to get that
information is because we've
we added that to the response
the on pre-response event we injected
that on every
view so now it's available anytime we
need it
so now we need to update our routes to
support the the views and authentication
so open up uh your source.routes folder
and let's create a new route
named auth so a new file named off.js
and here we're going to
bring in our boom
module
um we're going to define a
login and these this is just what i'm
what i'm about to show you is
an alternative way that you can define
some routes
and register those routes so in the past
we've just done server dot
route and specified the config in there
we can also
create individual json
or individual javascript objects of
those routes and then register them all
at once
with one server.register command so
that's what we're about to do
so our login route
the method
is get
path is login
and then we're going to specify some
configuration for this
um for this thing so the
handler
you know what we don't really need to
specify an option let's let's just
create a handler
which takes in a request
and if the request dot
auth is authenticated
if it's not authenticated
then we're going to return
a
message
we should probably never see this
message but um
just putting this in here for for
safekeeping
just in case we need our define our
callback
route for oauth pull off
callback and this is also
a get
the path is
authorization code
callback
the handler is
a takes in request
and the toolkit
and if the request
is not authenticated
then we throw a boom
error boom has
a number of
default response types
so there's a boom unauthorized
and but if they are authenticated then
we need to
set the session cookie so we're going to
use request
dot cookie off dot set
set that to the request off
credentials
and then return
h dot redirect
back to the home page in this case
we're going to set our options
the auth strategy for this particular
route
is octa and that's when it's going to
trigger
um if the person is not logged in
if there's no session it's going to
redirect them to
octa to log in
we also need a log out route
which is a get
pass path is log out
if the person is authenticated then
we're going to clear the session cookie
and then redirect them back to
the home page
and in our options
we're going to set the off mode
to try and what
what there are several there are i think
two or three off modes
that you can choose from uh the try
means it's going to
check to see if there's any
authentication information
available and it'll populate the
request.auth
object if auth mode was set
to none then request.auth would not be
populated with anything even if
that current request that person
is logged in and then request.mode
think it's called always
or required it's one of those
it will check to see if someone's logged
in if they're not logged in it will
initiate the uh
the strategy to to start a login
all right now we have our our three
routes defined
we need to register those
so we're going to export
a register function
that takes in a server
and
we're going to just register all these
at once
now we need to update our homepage
route so that it renders our ejs
view instead of returning a string
so under source
routes index
instead of returning this we need to
render our view
and we also need to register
our off
so after we register the server we'll
await
on after we register the api we'll
register
auth routes
and our homepage route we will
change um the handler
to return
uh h.view we're using the index
route and let's set the title to home
that's how you pass data you can pass a
javascript object
with a bunch of properties and things
to a view so the ejs template has that
data
to to work with and then
under options we want to have our auth
mode also equal to try
we also need a static route for our
static files
for like the index.css and and
javascript
that we'll create in a little while
and this is a get
the path is
really anything
and uh if we this is like a catch-all
if it does if it doesn't already find
another route
uh that's explicitly defined like a
like our login our home page our log out
route if if if none of those
routes match a current request then
this catch-all route will will handle it
and we're going to set this to a
directory
with the past path of
dist
this will be a folder that's that's
created for us automatically by our
build process it's going to
build our front end for us and generate
our js file and our our css file
well now that we have our authentication
added to the application we need to
update our
api to query the database based on the
current
logged in user and at minimum we also
need to create
some api routes for creating
updating and deleting events along with
those respective sql queries
so let's go ahead and add some of those
queries going to go to the
data events folder and create a new file
named add event dot sql
and i'm just going to copy in some some
code here
to save some time and
this is just an insert statement taking
in the
all the different columns we have and
then we're passing in
all the values as query string or not
query string
passing those in as parameter parameters
so this is a parameterized query
and then after the insert we're going to
return
the the newly generated id using the
the scope identity sql function
that returns the automatically generated
id
now let's create an update sql
we'll call this update event dot sql
again copy in some some code here
and very similar to the insert this is
the update
events setting the title to
the parameters title description
start date so forth i see
a little typo there
um where the id is the id and the user
id specified
and then after updating it return back
the newly
updated data
just as a double check and then um
let's create a delete event
and uh this one's really short i'm just
going to delete
the from the events table where id is
equal to
the id parameter and the user id is
equal to user id
and now let's update our events
dot index
uh javascript file to
use those those queries so in the
and the get events where we um
i'm just going to copy in some code to
save some time
so we need to add event
and that's going to take in javascript
objects that were
that's destructured into
the user id title description and so
forth
just like the the get events we'll we'll
get
uh the pool off the uh we'll get a
connection
um this needs to be
doesn't have to be but just to make
things consistent
we'll get the request and we're setting
all these values
on for parameters and then running the
query and returning the results
these could be these could be awaits but
the request.query
is a a promise
based so it'll it'll work with
the async and await as well and then we
need a
update event
again i'll rename this to connection for
consistency
the update event looks almost identical
to the
to the add or the insert statement
except
we're using a also including the id
of the event that we want to update
and then a delete
event
and finally we need to return those
functions
fro from here
so the client has those now let's update
the api
route under events
and instead of hard coding in the
the user id
we need to
get the actual user id that's
that's requested one thing we need to do
is we need to set
the options on
this handler or this route
so the off mode is set to
to try so that our authentication
information is populated
and then at the very top
of our handler will check
is the current user
authenticated
if not will return an
unauthorized
error now we don't have boom
um we need to pull that in
and then we can get the current user id
instead of hard coding
that value we can get that off of the
request.auth.credentials.profile.id
and everything else stays the same
now we also need
routes for creating events
and deleting events and updating events
i'm going to add a couple here just by
by pasting these in and i'll
i'll walk through what these do so
here's a route to um
to create a new event again
the auth mode is try we check to see if
it's
uh authenticated return unauthorized if
not
and then um we're going to pull
the start date start time all these
values
out of the request.payload so
when you post a json
document object to
an api endpoint that is
made available through happy using the
request.payload
object so we're pulling all those values
off of the payload
and then we're calling our api our
our data access layer client using the
add event
object our function passing in all those
parameters and we expect
uh coming back from that
update or that insert the the id
of the newly created event
and if there's an error let's uh console
log that error and
then return there's a
short a utility function on boom called
boomify it'll turn any error
into a happy boom error
so we're returning boomify that error
and then finally let's add a
delete route
and this route is a delete verb
and it takes in a this is how you
specify in the path
a a parameter
um as part of the path so events over we
got a placeholder here for id
and we get to that id using
request.params.id so instead of
request.payload which takes the
the data that was posted we're using
we're using params.id that gets the
parameters off of the
the path of the uri so
we get the user id from our credentials
and we
call delete event using the id
of the the event and the
current user id if um
if it was successful if the rows
affected
is equal to one then we respect return a
response code of
204 if we don't get
a record back then
we return not found
again if there's an error we'll
log this to the console
and return a boomified version of that
error
now it could do an update route here too
i'm going to leave that up to you as a
as an exercise it should be
very very similar to the
create event except instead of a
post verb it'd be a put verb and you
could use
uh just like the delete you could add an
id
on the path or you could
make it part of the of the put statement
either way
all right now let's um
we're going to create our ui
for our application and
we're going to use as i mentioned before
material css and
view and then some some other components
that'll
uh help us make the application
better so let's move over to back to the
uh
the command line and
we're going to install some dependencies
so npm install
we're going to use axios
version 0.19 to do some to
to actually do the communication from
the client front end
to the api uh
luxon is is part of luxon is part of the
date time ui that we're going to be
creating
i use the materialized css framework
version one uh the moment library
version two view
a view date time component
and another component called weak start
all right now let's create a folder in
the um in the application
i did it again closed many windows
let's create a folder in the application
in the root and we'll call this
client so in the client
we're going to create a new file
index.js
and in here
i'm going to put some copy in some code
notice we're using uh
the new module syntax for for
javascript we're going to import the
date time module
uh import the view materialize
css frameworks our date time
css and we're going to import app from
a new app component that we'll create
we're going to use that date time
component register that with view
and create a new view application and
and register that with the
app div tag that's in the front end
now going explaining
uh what all view does and and uh
how to use vue is out of the scope of
this
this tutorial uh but hopefully you'll be
able to follow along
and see how these things work
this is the code for our index we need
to create
a app view
component and in here
is a another big block of code
again unfortunately i don't um
it's out of the scope of this tutorial
to go through all of it or to
go through it line by line but hopefully
you can follow along
uh what some of these things are doing
its view is a
includes a template um where we can
have these uh
braces in there that that are like
tokens for
the different data that we want to uh
join with this template so these are
client-side templates
as opposed to server-side templates that
are in ejs
so view is our basically our template
engine
for doing client-side rendering so in
our
we're going to loop through the events
that we get back from the api
and and populate a table on the front
end
and then we have uh some forms
on the front end like we're going to add
an event
and this ad event has a start date
and a start time and we're using the
date time
components to be able to
show some some nice ui
based components that are going to be
like a
calendar type object or a time
component to work with and when we run
the application you'll see
um how that makes the the experience a
little bit nicer
so this is all the html for
the forms and we have some html for
a delete confirmation so if we're
deleting an event
it pops up this um
message box that asks for confirmation
and
based on whether they click the user
clicks on delete or cancel
there's behavior and then also as part
of this component we're defining
the the javascript that goes with it so
as i mentioned before we're using axios
to
do the api calls from the front end
we've got materialize in our moment
and as far as this view component we
have some
number of computed
properties we have a data property that
includes
you know all the information for a
single event
and we have these methods defined like
add event
and the axios will post that to our api
we have a confirm delete event a delete
event which actually
does the the delete calls that delete
api
endpoint and then we have some other
functions
such as format date and format time and
um formats the events that come
in and then finally we have a load
events that cause
calls that api endpoint that that get
endpoint and returns all those events
and reformats those
for display and we also
vue has a some life cycle
uh functions and one is called mounted
uh
we're using the mounted event to know
that the
the component has finished rendering the
initial view
and now it's safe to go and fetch all
the events that are currently
associated with the the user and load
those into the ui
and then we have some some style
a few customized style elements so let's
save this
now um to
generate the ui um
we're using as i said before um
the latest import uh
module import and export module syntax
we're using you know some things that
are modern javascript
and though those things might not be
available to every browser
we're also pulling in modules like
the materialized css we need a way to
build all this stuff
so that it's it's in a package that we
can deliver
to a browser so we're going to create a
build
process that will do all these
steps that we need to to generate a
final
javascript file a final css file
and so we need some dependencies for our
build process
so let's go back to the command line and
let's use npm install this time these
are these are development dependencies
uh they don't need we're not needed for
production we're going to build
everything that we need at the time of
deployment
um and not um rebuild anything
during production so uh we need we're
gonna use nodemon
which is uh not necessary for
building our assets but this is a
really nice utility that will make your
life as a developer much easier nodemon
monitors your project directory for any
changes to files and then restarts
your node.js application so you don't
have to
continually be going back and
using control c to stop a web
application and restart it
uh nodemon does that for you
automatically so we need no
mon we're going to use mpe run
npm run all which is a nice little
utility to
chain together a bunch of npm scripts
we're going to use parcel bundler
to do our bundling process of vue
and css and javascript
parcel is similar to webpack but it's
it's kind of like
zero config zero code by default
it can understand a lot of different
front end projects and create a uh
appropriate bundle of those
so that's just a way of saving some time
we need a
view component compiler utils
for our um our bundling process
and a
view template
compiler version two
all right now that that's done let's
update our package.json file
to include some build scripts
so package.json is a
has a or node.js with npm
has a way of defining
scripts that um we don't have to use
something like gulp or
grunt or any other kind of script
runners we can use
npm itself to do a lot of those kinds of
things so in the scripts uh we'll
define a build script
that's going to use parcel to
build the client folder
and the entry point that we want to
point it to
is index.js
we're going to define a dev
script which will use nodemon
and we're going to specify that it watch
the client folder
and we want to watch the source folder
both of those for any changes and the
file types that we want it to
watch include javascript ejs
sql view and css so if we make
a change to any of those types of files
nodemon will detect that and restart
the application so if it detects one of
those things then
we tell it to run use npm
run dev start
what's dev start we also need to define
that so dev
start is
npm run all
build and start
so we need a start um
script and that's just simply
run node with a
in the current directory and that's
it you can run any script
defined in your command or terminal line
with the npm run label and
as i mentioned before nodemon's a
fantastic utility so
only thing we need to do now is come
back here and run npm
run dev and that should run
nodemon and kick off our build process
hmm i don't think it ran
our our uh
build process so let's go back and
and look at this again npm run
dev start oh i'm
forgot to include an exec parameter so
exec
tells it what command to actually run
and not just run
node by default it does something like
this
but if we wanted to specify a particular
script to run we need to use the exact
parameter so let's try that again
npm run dev this time
it kicks off parcel
now we have our local host running
oh no an internal error
well let's switch over to the console
and see
what uh what's going on all right
so there's an internal error reference
to
message is not defined oh
so our homepage is expecting to get a
message
sent to the template and we're not
passing a message
we're just passing the title so let's go
over to
the the templates folder under source
or actually the template's fine
remember it's looking for a message
in the paragraph so we need to go to our
routes
for the home page and we're just passing
a title as a home let's also pass a
message of
something like welcome now what should
happen
is that node mon nodemon
recognizes the change we just made to
the file
and automatically restarts the server
so if we go back to the browser and
refresh the page
boom we get our login
something strange though is going on
here we're not getting any of the
stylings
that we would expect to get and i think
i know what the problem is
so in our index.js when we just
created the server route
we did not specify that
the
um
the off mode should be
set
actually this auth mode we can just set
this to
false and
so our server restarts let's try it
again
now we get the the stylings
like we'd expect and click on the login
button
it's going to prompt us to log into our
octa
account and
since we have regis self registration
turned on
there's a link down here that says if
you don't have an account you can sign
up for an account
it's really cool
oh no got another error what's what do
we got
happening this time cannot read property
first name
of undefined so i must have
messed something up with the uh
the data maybe i mis misspelled
something
so in our routes um
off plugin
or let's see our off
plug in
instead of profile i called it
process you probably saw me make that
mistake
let's try it again so it automatically
restarted
and now we have our events we have no
events
yet because the two dummy events that we
added to the application
database earlier those are no longer in
there
so click on start date and we've got a
nice little calendar pop
up here and time
we've got a nice time picker so let's
say
3 p.m
and we won't specify an end date and
we'll call the
appointment just um
coffee of course you could set that for
every hour
of the day as far as i'm concerned
and we'll click submit and that
goes off and makes an api request to
insert that data
into the database and returns uh
updates our list of events up here
so if i were to refresh the page we
still get
a list of the one event let's add one
more event
let's say kind of like our conference
we'll say
it starts on april the 1st
and ends on april the 2nd
a virtual conference
submit that and now we've got our
virtual conference if you want to delete
one of these we click
delete and it's going to ask us to
confirm if we click
ok then it calls the api to delete that
from the database and refreshes our list
of events
so i declare this application
a success well i hope you
liked learning about node.js and using
sql server
a little bit about happy and how to
authenticate your application with octa
if you like the content please
click the thumbs up and subscribe so
that you can find
content from us in the future thank you
so much and i hope you have a great day